alright question 14 so we've got some
box plots here well we've got one box
plot at the moment we're going to draw
another one shortly they display the
results of a diagnostic tasks at by two
different classes
I guess it's two different classes over
time so if you have a look here I've got
and I'll come down to the rest of this
data in a second because this took me a
long time to write so I figured I will
pre write it for you and we will discuss
it in a second I'm going to look at the
results of the 20/20 class and then I'm
going to use them to create the box plot
now you need to remember what what does
a box plot actually tell you well
there's are five important spots on a
box plot one two three four five if we
go from in order you've got the lowest
score down here and if you have a look
at the horizontal axis here for the
marks you can see they go from lowest to
highest so there's the lowest score
actually maybe going all the way to the
other end you can see that implies
here's the highest score over on the
right hand side right there in the
middle as we've seen before this is the
median so it's not the mean or the mode
it's the middle score here the median
and that just leaves your arma 2 and
this is where you need to remember what
we call our quartiles right now the
median it breaks up your entire set of
scores into two equal sections so if you
had you know a hundred students then the
score would break your top fifty and
your bottom fifty into two different
groups but these quartiles we call them
q1 and q3 because the the median is q2
q1 and q3 or q1 q2 and q3 together they
don't break up the data into two they
break the data into four so that's why
we call them war tiles and you can sort
of extend this you know you've got
quartiles which let's not go into using
a razor
you've got quartiles which break your
data set into four you've got des îles
which break your data set into ten equal
chunks and then a very common one is the
percentiles which break your data up
into 100 different sections and of
course the most common percentile that
people are very familiar with is the 8r
so people's 8r tells you you know if
you've got an ATAR of 75 that means
roughly better than 75 where you perform
better than 75% of the same cohort who
did the exam with you so we know let's
just push this over to the side here we
know what these data points are supposed
to be how are we going to find them for
the 20/20 class well because all of
these data points here lowest q1 q2 q3
and the highest they kind of depend on
order so we need to look at this data
set here which is kind of a mishmash of
different numbers in random order or
maybe it's in a different order like say
alphabetical order which is not very
useful to us and we need to put it in
numerical order and I'm gonna say
ascending is probably the easiest now
very practically the way that I do this
is I look here and I don't want to miss
any of my scores so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna cross off scores as I write
them down in order I look and I see what
is the lowest one that I can identify
conveniently it's actually the tenth
which is the first score there so I'll
cross out 10 to say okay this one's done
the next one along again I'm looking
across the entire line conveniently it's
it's also 16 so that's done but the the
next highest score is definitely not 30
this loads of scores that are less than
that
so I look and I see a cross on the right
hand side it's 18 so I'm gonna write
down 18 then I'm gonna cross it out I'm
gonna keep on going all the way up and
this way I won't miss any scores and
what I'll end up with is an ordered list
of all of the data points so I'm gonna
write let's see here the next one I can
see is twenty cross that out
oops just go down to the next page by
accident what do we got next here 27 no
sorry I missed the 22 there it's right
there then the 27 cross that one out
next one by looks of it that's the first
one in the 30s cross out 30 32 is all
the way on the right hand side 33 comes
up next 34 comes up once and then it
comes up twice 35 just left over there
on the left hand side and then the last
number is 38 okay so what have I got
here well for starters I can already
read off the first the lowest score in
the higher
score immediately you can see that
that's going to be 10 for the lowest and
38 for the highest so when I go up to my
new dot plot up here I'm gonna find
where 10 is I'm gonna draw a vertical
line like so and then I'm going to go
over to 38 and I'm going to draw another
vertical line over there so I've got my
bottom score on my top score that's good
but now to work out all the rest of them
I need to think of it more carefully so
remembering that firstly the easiest one
to find is the median because it just
divides it into half I need to know how
many scores there are in total so when I
go ahead and count it looks like 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 so if I've got 13
scores then the middle school will be
the seventh score let's find that on the
list the seventh score by the looks of
it's going to be 30 and you can see
there and there's going to be six scores
to the left and six scores to the right
so I've divided it into two even groups
so I'm gonna find 30 that's going to be
on my graph here this they so there's
going to be my median I might even label
that q2 so I don't forget what it is and
then to find out my q1 my lower quartile
and maia q3 my upper quartile I repeat
that process but for the data points
that I had below so when you have a look
you can see I've got let's highlight it
in another color that I haven't used yet
let's use pink so this is the lowest set
of scores gee that's really bright isn't
it you can see right in the middle here
between 18 and 20 is 19 that's halfway
in between so 19 breaks that group into
a group of three and another group of
three and then if you have a look at the
data set on the right it would be a
between these two scores which happened
to be the same score so 34 is going to
be the upper quartile if you like it's
the median of the top half and the
medium of the bottom half so now I find
where those are on my vertical my
horizontal axis up above here so 19 is
between 18 and 20 so
vertical line there and then what do we
say 34 so here we go all right so I've
done all five of my vertical lines
that's why we call it a five number
summary Q 1 Q 2 and Q 3 and then my
minimum of my maximum and now all I need
to do is turn these lines into boxes and
whiskers so just gonna put this
horizontal line in here there's one
whisker there's the other one and then
here comes the box in the middle it's
not the neatest but you get the idea
okay so I'm done that is the box and
whisker pot for 2020 and now we're
supposed to use that you can see down
the bottom to compare and contrast the
two classes now this is really important
the question says refer to and then it
names a few things which if you want to
get full marks on this you want to
identify those fairly deliberately it
says the skewness of the distributions
the measure of location and then the
measure of spread so let's talk about
each one of those in turn so skewness
well skewness talked about which way is
the data leaning so I will give you an
example quickly here what does it look
like if you've got a sort of you know
symmetrical data set it's going to look
like this if you were doing a plot of it
but on a box plot on a box and whisker
plot you can see what it means is that
your lowest and your highest are
symmetrically positioned around q1 and
q3 so that's why you can see I've
written that the 2019 class has a
symmetrical distribution but if you have
a look at the 2020 class there's a
negative skew now what does that mean
well if I go up here and again draw you
an example when you talk about skew
you've got positive skew negative skew I
always remember it's a bit weird it's a
bit counterintuitive because the skier
refers to which direction is the tail
going in it's not where most of your
scores are it's where most of your
scores aren't so a negative skew would
be something like this you can see I've
got my tail pointing in the negative
direction and that's what we have here
most of the scores here
stop toward the top you can see q2 and
q3 are quite close to that upper value
there whereas q1 and the lowest value
over here on the right hand side they're
quite spaced out so you can see this gap
here and this gap here are very large
compared to and these gaps over here the
larger those gaps are the more spread
out the students are which indicates
there are fewer students down the
negative end of the graph so that's why
I've said there's a negative skew for
the 20/20 class as opposed to the
symmetrical distribution so that's a
point of contrast there's stronger
performance for the 20/20 class as
compared to the 2019 class I'm going to
move down and now I'm going to talk
about a measure of location here so what
does location mean that's talking about
where in terms of the marks where are my
marks actually positioned where the
students positioned the only measures of
location that we have really here are
the medium you might use mean but we
haven't got that calculated here so the
median for the 2019 class is 23 and the
median for the 20/20 class is 30 and
that's way up like seven hallmarks so
that's why I've written it's
significantly higher and there's much
better performance there then we go to
measure of spread now you've got two
different kinds of measure of spread
here you've got range
and then you've got interquartile range
which is the difference between q1 and
q3 so I've written about both you can
calculate the range by doing top value
takeaway bottom value which for the 2019
class is 26 for the 20/20 class it's 28
and then you do the interquartile range
let me just write it in here for you as
q3 takeaway q1 so you can go ahead read
from the graph above it might help you
if you go and say Oh q1 where is that
it's going to be 16 here and then it is
30 over here so 30 takeaway 16 you can
see where I've got the 14 from you go
ahead and calculate it for 2020 as well
and you get these results now excuse me
it looks to me like the range in the
interquartile range are very very
similar between the two classes so
that's not a point of contrast that's a
point of comparison
so you can see here I said the classes
were consistent in the gap between the
poorer results and the stronger results
so I guess from skewness and a location
point of view they're quite different
but from a spread point of view they are
quite similar now you can see I've laid
out my solution in this kind of table
form you could have written it in
sentences or even in dot points the real
key is was your logic and was your you
know the data points you referred to
were they clear could we know what you
were talking about on the basis of
reading when you're talking what you had
written in that space there